everyone's talking about taking down the
Confederate flag we wanted to see who's
still buying it okay just to give you a
flavor of the different type of
Confederate gear they have here in the
store this is a flag for $5.00 this is a
cutting board about $17 this right here
a hundred percent Egyptian cotton sheets
this is Joel a loyal customer and the
only guy in the strip mall willing to
talk to us what does this flag represent
to you my heritage in 1861 South
Carolina was the first state to stand up
for its own rights the history of that
flag has so much to do with the southern
heritage not slavery and to take a
magnifying glass and exemplify one
subject that is not good that no human
being should ever own another but to say
that the entire culture and our heritage
was wrong for 1% of what went on is just
really sad
at a tourist area close to where slaves
were once auctioned everyone had an
opinion what does this flag represent to
you I would say insubordination it's
like a symbol of hate I guess the read I
mean for what it means or what it stands
for
I mean why is it by higher than the
American flag that's my opinion clip
let's just say all right try to use
prejudice so far the past is what it
means to me in the past I grew up in the
south and it's just part of our heritage
I'm from a city of five flags and that
is one of the flags that we represent in
our city and so to us it is not just
about racism it is about our Southern
heritage and what if people say well
part of that representation of the south
is the history of slavery s tree that
mean history is history I mean you can
look all over the world in there's
history of good and bad that this is
just part of our history